singer turned politician Bobby wine
celebrates his escape from Ugandan
security forces by riding through the
streets of the capital Kampala cheered
on by supporters wine was due to hold an
Independence Day concert at a beach
resort but hours before he was due to
perform soldiers and police officers
surrounded both his home and the venue
multitudes of soldiers and policemen
were deployed at one-lap beach for Salah
and indeed even my home this very place
was sealed by the police and the
military they deployed very many police
officers many many more much more than
we needed for our show to go on Bobby
why he became a member of parliament
three years ago is known for his
politically charged songs calling for
change in a country where you erima
Sevigny has been president for more than
three decades his activism has won him
International sympathy but not from the
Camden government the police has been
targeting us has been blocking our
shores and indeed they went ahead to
block the show that was supposed to go
on today it will be remembered that this
has been the hundred and fifty sixth
show that has been blocked by a
policeman Ugandan police say the concert
wasn't approved because they didn't have
the staff to provide security for the
event wine who is standing against my
Sevigny in the 2021 presidential
election says his opposition to the
government will continue Victoria Gaytan
be al Jazeera